all right
[Music]
okay so uh
um
I gave you sort of the
Central tenet of the
semi-ring framework approach
a nice thing that happened when we
developed this was that
it allowed us to make some sense of
competing proposals for what's
provenance should be
whether it was called lineage or
whatever it was called or even pedigree
it wasn't clear how
how they all sort of should be compared
there was some intuitive
understanding that some of the proposals
for provenance were
expressive and some were less expressive
and
we would have liked to to be able to say
okay if you do this kind of provenance
this is what you can do with it and so
on
so um
it was a nice property of this algebraic
abstraction that the previous proposals
for provenance were captured as
particular cases so you've seen the
polynomials and so of course you can bet
that I had slides that refer to the
semi-ring of polynomials as one
submitting to rule them all
inevitably because it is the general
motion I want the freely generated and
so on
but there were other interesting uh
examples that were used at the time so
there was a lot of work in
probabilistic databases and in
probabilistic databases you kind of well
sort of this the step-by-step approach
when you cannot actually do shortcuts
and be faster so the passive approach is
first to compute a Boolean provenance
that is for every Tuple to get a Boolean
expression that captures essentially its
provenance
and for positive queries positive
relational algebra
um these are monotone sometimes called
or positive Boolean expressions with
variables again from X which corresponds
to the input tuples but of course you
have to identify Boolean Expressions
that are equivalent which can be defined
for example by saying that they give you
the same truth value for every
assignment through the time
and this was in fact
related to a very influential
early work for income in incomplete
databases and it was called C tables now
C tables are even more General but if
you consider C tables in which
the only place where you use variables
is in labeling of tuples and you use
only monotone Expressions uh then you
can you have essentially possible
relations and this early work was an
email in skilipsky 1984. in fact
I do recall that the first time I was
talking
in those times to Sergio habitable for
the first time and he wanted to know
what I'm doing and I said provenance and
he said uh you mean uh sea tables so
and he's absolutely he was and as usual
absolutely right that it's just a matter
of looking at the sea tables in a
different way than describing complete
databases and you can think of them as
capturing provenance
um so they were actually used for
probabilistic databases in a less
elegant way but early on by some people
if you're a relic and zimani
and then this book by Dan and Dan and
Christoph and Chris Ray
this book actually calls it calls his
Boolean Expressions lineage
okay
[Laughter]
now a few years earlier an approach to
uh to to provenance in which the
provenance was simply a collection of
Tuple IDs of all the Tuple ideas that
you could touch in your revaluation
uh was also called lineage so that was
in the work of Tui and Jennifer with
them
um and they too have nothing to do with
each other so but you know
and then and then there was this really
influential paper uh that introduced why
provenance so in why provenance don't
look at that okay just think in why
provenance the provenance can be thought
of as a set of sets of Tuple IDs so the
set inside uh they were they called them
Witnesses each of them was a witness for
one of the reasons why you would derive
the the Tuple and hence the name y
provenance and that's really uh very
nice because it is there is still an
uncompletely not yet completely
fulfilled relationship between
provenance and causality it hasn't been
completely examined I believe
it should
Okay so
uh so so what you do is for example for
multiplication you take this set of sets
and this set of sets and this set of
sets you take a set from the first one
except from the second one you take the
union you collect all these unions okay
uh so this was called why provenance
this is the work of one chutan Peter
binnamon and Sanji uh Sanjeev Kana
uh another uh work around the same time
a few years uh was uh in a project
called Trio and in this project and it's
this project they of course called it
also lineage but it has nothing to do
with the other two incarnations of
lineage
and it wasn't quite clear what it was
but DJ green had this idea of thinking
of it as bags of of set Witnesses
and
that is actually the right way to think
about it so and what does it mean a bag
because you may have a witness that can
be a cause in more than one way
I can't forget about this so it's also
called lineage and this was elucidated
by TJ in his ICD TPA but I'll have a lot
more to say in a moment
um
in addition to to these constructions
there are also algebraic properties that
in fact lead to some very interesting
semi Rings one of them is
idents that is set semantics but is in a
general sense so another one is what's
called absorption so this is from the
theory of lattices so absorption can be
understood in
two equivalent ways so this is what in
lattices they call absorption a plus a
times B is a but this is easier to
remember so a semi ring is absorptive if
one plus a is equal to one and it this
implies item potent so absorptive semi
rings are either importance on
on steroids
and it turns out that these were also
very useful properties so
the semi-ring in which the poly we call
them either important polynomials in
which instead of having natural numbers
as coefficients you just have booleans
in other words you have no coefficients
uh because the ones whose coefficient
zero you just don't write them down
and this is the commutative identity
generated by X unfortunately the
literature when this when you talk about
an item potency ring they mean that plus
is either important and when you talk
about the commutative simmering they
mean that pains is commutative
go figure but you know I'm just
following tradition
and it turns out that this B of X
actually this item bottom polynomials
can be seen as a the result of applying
a congruence the congruence generated by
all uh ident potency equations
to the polynomials that uh to to the
provenance monuments n of x
and there is also something that you do
by looking at the absorptive polynomials
and I should say what absorbed what
absorption comes down to
so if you have for example
a polynomial that looks like this
okay
let's say
then X is going to absorb
both x square Y and X Y squared so the
whole thing is actually equivalent to X
to this polynomial
so that's what absorption
very roughly means but in the in that
big picture we'll see a more interesting
example and this one is also can be seen
as a result of quotienting by the
congruence that's generated by the
absorption identities this was used in a
paper
by sudipa spearheaded by sudeepa with
Daniel deutschentovanilo uh on circuits
for data log
uh so back to that picture
so the way in which we can see how these
compare that I like
is the following so in the full semi
ring of polynomials consider this
polynomial doesn't it's not a
particularly
related to a query we just wrote wrote
down an example in particular to get to
get this kind of provenance you need a
query that's quite complicated because
there's many ways of doing Alternatives
and so on
so
from these provenance polynomials there
are two ways to simplify them one way is
to drop the exponents this down arrow
EXP
means dropping the exponents when you
drop the exponents you get this
polynomial
notice that
actually the 2x squared y
becomes 2xy and there is another X Y so
you have 3xy
5y plus x e and these are in fact
although this might have come as a
surprise to the uh people who invented
Trio these are in fact the trio lineage
Expressions you can see them this way
uh and then
if you instead of dropping the exponents
you drop the coefficients so 2x Square
you know this becomes x square y plus X
Y plus y squared plus XZ that in fact is
the same thing as quotient Thing by the
item potents
okay
now uh there is further simplification
so if from this
um
from from this Boolean polynomials I I'd
important polynomials you drop the
exponents again just like what you did
here
you get the Y
provenance of tan winnerman and Kana
if you do the same but dropping the X
coefficients from the trio provenance
you get also the Y provenance
and this commutes that is you know you
for every each of these arrows remember
is a subjective for amorphous so there's
a very clear way in which multiple
different provenances in the above
semi-ring actually map to the same
simplified proven provenance in the
below same meaning
if you apply absorption right what you
get here so you see you have x square y
plus X Y plus y squared plus XZ but if
you apply absorption X Y is going to
absorb x square y
but y Square doesn't absorb anything
so you get X Y plus y squared plus XZ
these polynomials we call them
absorptive
polynomials and they were useful as a
short representation for circuits for
data log prominence but then later on we
found them as just the right thing with
that additional twist for provenance for
what's called fixed Point logic that's
first other logic Wesley switch points
and greatest fixed points and the
negation is dualizes between these fixed
points and greatest fixed points okay
and then finally if you drop the
exponents or you do absorption from
surfboard why you get the Boolean
expressions
and then finally and this is the
weirdest operation if you identify plus
and times
and that is also in some sense a
homework I mean these are subjective
homoses you get the the original lineage
of three and Widow
so it's XYZ yes
no because well in this expression for
this particular one you do
but there are examples yeah guys thought
exactly the same thing but there are
examples in which these are incomparable
so for example
uh if you have
um
yeah X Y
X Y plus x y z x y plus x y z for
example yeah
yes
am I missing something or is it a bug
that's possible
if possible doesn't have X Y as a term
is
absolutely because it has it's absorbed
by why because when you drop the
exponent in y it becomes in y squared it
becomes Y and then it absorbs X Y it's
not about it it's a feature
okay all right so
so you know in terms of understanding
what the heck is going on this was very
useful
[Music]
picture for us
for us okay
um
I think I'm gonna skip the next thing
but there is a way to explain
this picture here you can think of the
these polynomials as bags of bags and
this as
sets of bags and this is bags of sets
and this is set of sets and there's a
way to explain why dropping exponents is
a is a
homomorphism but you have to think of a
generalized notion of polynomial in
which not just the coefficients but in
fact also the uh exponents are elements
of a general
same meaning or monoid at least
yeah so I made the mistake
if you are if you are referring to the
picture that appears in our 2017 box
paper
um I made a mistake I should have said
that right from the beginning I I
instead of seeing this as just dropping
each one I say oh this must be a
consequence of either Motors of
multiplication and it is but that's not
what's going on
because in Trio I mean why
multiplication is not identical
think of X Plus y times X Plus y
okay
Okay so
I think I'm ready to
questions because I'm ready to go to my
next
foreign
before we
did all these games with semi Rings
there were two things that one would
call Classics classical semantics for
queries set semantics and back semantics
there's also a version called setback
semantics which is the realistic one
which is that usually databases are
stored inside semantics but as you
operate through queries it becomes bugs
because it bags because it's too
expensive too
to remove duplicates okay
but now that you know we have a
generalization to K relations and being
dutiful mathematicians we have to see
what that means right for General case
so this turns out
to have led to a very beautiful paper of
TJ green again I'm being immodest but at
least I'm praising TJ but of course she
was my students okay
about containment and equivalence of
conjunctions and unions of conjunctions
queries where K is actually ranging over
various provenance Emirates and this was
uh
there is a journal paper about this
appeared in 2011 that has a lot of
details and I strongly recommend it as a
way of learning things about this whole
framework
so what's the deal consider so now we
have to be a bit more formal consider
accountable domain of constants
and a k relation I never gave this
definition I talked about care relations
but you all assume the same thing but
what is a k relation correlation is a
function
it's a function from well an NRA
relation from D to the N to K
that has what's called a finite support
so what's the support all those suppose
whose annotation is non-zero and that
has to be finite because of course there
are infinitely many tuples ones you say
the countable domain of constants okay
a conjunctive query let's use this
syntax
has to be considered a little more
generally so if you know something about
the back semantics of conjunctive
queries you know that you really should
consider
because of the multiplicities you should
consider bodies of conjunctive queries
in which the same atom appears more than
once if you want to have canonical
databases and things like that so so the
body has to be a bag of atoms not just a
set of atoms which is the usual thing
that we are using
and uh
there is a way to define semantics
directly for uh for uh
conjunctive queries consider evaluation
which is a function from the variables
that appear in the conjunctive query
call it X bar
to D
okay here I am assuming that
this full but it's not it doesn't have
to be full so so instead of this x you
can think of the Union of X1 XM
Okay so
and this is the value of the same ring
and it's a sum of products of course so
um and that you already knew from Angus
lectures
how important it is
notice that this sum is actually finite
because the product it turns out is
non-zero for only finally many
assignments otherwise what does it mean
an infinite sound yeah
so let's also Define query equivalence
and containment
so consider instances as usual okay
instance you interprets every relation
as a k relation
uh let's denote by q i the answer of the
query applied to a k instance I
and then yes
and then two queries are equivalent with
respect to K semantics if for any K
instance they give the same answer
uh and you would like to like you we do
for for certain Bank semantics to also
Define to understand the equivalence we
Define it to containment
so you'd like to have something like
containment uh but the question is what
is this inequality operation between
because this these are all values in a
semi ring or at least in uh relation K
relations and what does it mean to say
less than or equal
and for that we need to talk about A New
Concept that Dan is going to
get to the bottom of it tomorrow yes
what would you
Miss Jenna for multiple cases
so
um
[Music]
but usually that's in set semantics or
index
usual
but this is equivalence with respect to
K semantics so for any fixed case
equivalent to respect you could
generalize it and instead of having K
you could also consider a class of same
meanings and say that this is equivalent
for every single in a given class that's
also a valid interesting concept yes
okay
so what do we know uh
uh classical results
what sets semantics and for back
semantics which famously were called
real queries by Chowdhury and vardy
um so we know that big containment and B
equivalents are NP complete and that's
the result that
essentially created relational database
Theory
by Chandra and Merlin for unions of
conjunctive queries the result was by
sage and yanakakis
and notice that if you want to extend
this to positive relational algebra it's
not as simple because the translation
from positive relation algebra to unions
of conjunctive queries can have an
exponential blow up
so actually B containment B equivalents
are Pi 2p complete
for that
and that result I always thought it was
also inside but
but for kyun I I saw something you wrote
that it's in yank axis 82 but I haven't
found a place
huh
it is by them so I mean it's essentially
so
um
and then
very interesting things happen when it
came to containment
so equivalence of uh sorry equivalent to
bag equivalence is actually GI complete
for conjunctive queries and for unions
of contract people so what's share
complete GI stands for graph isomorphism
in the complexity class of the problems
which are interredusable with graph
isomorphism
is
not it's not clear people do not know
exactly it is widely believed not to be
the same as MP
uh
some people hope it is actually gonna
fall into three times but uh it's for
the moment all we can do is just to say
okay this is it's complete for every for
uh GI for this class or GI Graphics
modules
and very interestingly
um containment with back semantics is
actually undecidable for unions of
contracted queries
and therefore also for uh the first
civilization and non-recursion data like
that's a result of your English
and the containment Bank semantics
containment is open
uh it's
an annoyingly open problem and we have
some people who have really gotten to
the bottom of this and they still
uh Heaven quite but you know maybe this
program will what do you think I would
like talks about December we'll have
about 20 years yes by December we might
have an answer
so for Kieran with collaborators have
shown that it's also undecidable for uh
conjunctive queries with inequalities
and for Keon together with Mahmoud and
hung and Dan they have a very
interesting paper where they show it's
equivalent to some hard problems you you
told me they're hard I don't know hard
problems in information Theory okay
which people have tried presumably to
solve and couldn't right I'm a junior
you can still agree or disagree with me
okay okay
so it's a hard problem all right great
uh so uh you know TJ did not attack this
hard problem but
um look how interesting anyway let's
start by defining what does less less
than or equal I mean if I may make a
comment yes please
the open problem
the only lower bound we know is that we
had who comes from the set case
where they had made a claim it is
yeah it's been withdrawn right but I'm
saying if you buy me a beer I'll tell
you funny story
I'm just mentioning this in case people
want to dig in the original childhood
but today is the problem yeah yeah so so
yeah there is there is a result that was
withdrawn that there is a lower bound
that we don't know how to grow
okay
thank you
so anyway how do we how do we compare
for inequality queries in an arbitrary
setting well the Arbiter is anything
better be uh have some notion of
ordering and luckily there is a notion
of ordering which we knew already
because we needed it for data log in
order to get fixed points it's called
natural order
uh this is very biblical isn't it a
natural author's name so we say a is
less than b if you can add something to
a to get to B okay
so that actually only uses addition and
it's easy to see it's a pre-order in any
additive monoid so what's missing is
anti-symmetry so when K is when this
order is anti-symmetric case called
naturally ordered
it's easier to say who is not not
naturally ordered the Rings are not
naturally ordered like Z okay but pretty
much everybody else that you've seen in
my previous uh in my talk uh earlier
those are all naturally ordered uh semi
rings so this is a natural kind of
ordering therefore right
um if the semi ring is either important
then it is naturally ordered
and you might recognize the definition
of ordering from lattices okay so a is
less than b whenever a plus b is equal
to B so when the same meaning is either
important this is uh an ordering
and it's easy to see that the
homomorphism between naturally ordered
same meaning a semi-ling homomorphism is
monotone preserves preserves this
natural water
and now what TJ uh encoders observed
is that if we have a subjective
homomorphism and it remembers rejective
homework is play interesting roles here
remember that picture if you have a
subjective homomorphism
then for any queries that commute with
the homomorphis so that means the
queries for which the commutation that
square was proven
the following holds if q1 is contained
in Q2 then Q is contained in Q2 with
respect to K semantics all K instances
then it's contained in Q2 with respect
to L semantics all L instances and the
place where you need it to be subjective
is because you want to take an L
instance and construct the K instance
out of it so you want everything that
that labels the tuples with L values to
have some K values
okay so this easy easy to check very
trivial result
already gives us a picture
uh we we can actually take that that
picture with all those subjective horses
that I showed you and it gives you a
comparison between containment with all
those uh provenance semi links
now it turns out that another kind of
simulating that is also very important
is What's called the positive semitting
so I'm going to give the full definition
because then we'll need it also tomorrow
so this dagger this is eilenberg's
definition and it's traditional
uh
this dagger this operation from an
arbitrary summary in K into B
is giving you false when a is zero when
a is not zero it's giving you two so it
sort of maps false to zero and
everything else sorry
non-zero sorry zero to false and
everything entails that's not zero it
Maps it to true
okay
and
you have the following characterization
these properties which you would like to
have zero different from one
if a plus b is zero then both A and B
are zero if a times B is zero then at
least one of them is zero a zero B zero
these together are equivalent to that
being simulating homomorphism so this
observation goes back to eilenberg
actually it's a book written in the 70s
so
if you have a positive
semi-ring
and you have queries that commute with
this particular
home office that is or any home office
then you also have the fact that
containment with respect to an arbitrary
summary in K implies set containment
containment in set semantics okay
so these are kind of situational
results that that describe how this
properties can relate to each other
they're they're cheap cheap lower bounds
as it were okay
uh other General considerations for
example because of the universality
property you can also show that
containment with respect to the Natural
to the polynomials
Roman and polynomials implies
containment in any semi ring
you do have to have a big enough X
so
now
for item potency meetings then you can
go back and forth between containment of
conjuncting the Union of conjunctive
queries
and also
containment and equivalents are
interview of unions of conjunctive
queries are interreducible these are
also cheap results
and this one is a little more
interesting
for a positive semi ring
and for conjunctive queries without self
joins
you can actually show that equivalence
in with respect to K is the same as
isomorphism of the queries
okay this one is a little less immediate
given all this
my man TJ sat down
rolled up his sleeves
and he actually compared these Notions
for every uh provenance emitting that
you saw in that diagram
isomorphism so this is when queries like
isomorphism isomorphic as hypergraphs
yeah
yes and how it's compatible with the
hardness of the equivalent I mean DTI
completeness of equivalents or bags
this is a ice monkey
they're not sure but
oh it's just okay it's just the
isomorphism of the query and this itself
isomorphism program yes okay
Okay so
one of the greatest things in that paper
is how beautiful the results are
concentrated in a few diagrams and makes
life easy for people who sell them
so here is what we have it's really
interesting so what you see in this
diagram when you see a an implication
sign that means that
containment with respect to the same
meaning B of X implies containment with
respect to the simulating Y of x
when you see an equivalence the
implication goes in the other direction
as well all the implications that are
only in One Direction TJ has proved them
strict
that is he gave counter examples of
queries that are of one kind but not the
other
so here is a fascinating
observation
so this is decidable we'll see in a
moment this is decidable we'll see in a
moment and this is open
sandwiched
contentment with respect to to any it's
implied by something that is decidable
and
and GI complete and this one is a
several NP complete
and this is open
okay
um but you know we could go through the
whole picture but
maybe another thing to observe is that
both containment and equivalence with
respect to
the Boolean expression the booleans
emiring is the same as set containment
slash equivalence and in fact this is
even more General you can have here any
distributive lattice it turns out these
results have also been looked at what's
a situation
okay uh this is for unions of
conjunctive queries
all right
um
I don't know what
especially to say here
except that you know
we were able to understand better
some of these more mysterious similar
things like three of x
from the properties they have with
respect to containment and
equivalents
and finally
perhaps the most interesting result is
the decision procedures
so
where you see this double line here
these are results that were known
which I summarized at the beginning so
conjunctive query containment and
equivalence close NP complete
unions of conjunctive queries
containment and equivalence
course MP complete for
for set semantics for bag semantics
this one is the open one this is
GI graph isomorph is complete this one
is undecidable this is graph isomorph is
complete this is the open problem
everything else here was pretty much
characterized
as either MP complete
or
GI complete
with two exceptions
four
containment of unions of conjunctive
queries
with respect to the
provenance polynomials and the trio
polynomials
um TJ actually showed that it is in P
space but she doesn't know what the
the lower bound is uh he suspects his
piece base complete that's you know I
didn't even put it at the end as open
prawns because I had to be more General
but that's something that if you look at
this the paper is is full of techniques
um the techniques are generalizing the
idea of containment mapping which is
used for for containment of set
semantics
uh so containment mappings with some
twists
but for this there is a different
technique for the P space upper bound
and we don't know what the lower bound
how to get the lower bound
yes
they are NPR
but they don't seem to be in NP
okay
um
so I thought these were such beautiful
results that I would just
show you as a way to entice you to read
some of these papers that's really my
secret and also Secret
so what's missing
negation yes that was the first question
that was asked
so uh in the original paper in 2007
negation was ignored and it was well it
was listed as an unanswered question
and
um since then there were three
essentially three approaches to attack
the problem the first one
I'm glad to say that
the culprit is here Flores
I apologize
[Laughter]
this is a an extremely uh interesting
approach so the approach is okay well
you've got a plus for that you got the
times for join why don't we introduce an
operation for minus
except that when you subtract when you
do difference of back semantics you use
what's what's called not minus but monus
that is uh three minus zero three minus
five is actually zero right
and uh you can it turns out Define monos
in an arbitrary summary like this but it
may not exist now the beautiful fact is
that it exists for the booleans and
natural numbers even the Tropicals
emitting the viterbies emitting the
fuzzy submitting Boolean algebras even
some of these polynomials
and it can be as was discovered by
Flores and Antonella uh it can be
equationally axiomatized not by them I I
mean those done work a long time ago by
some algebraized
some real algebraized
not like us okay
and I learned with excitement from Dan
that is actually monos is actually used
also in in your work on uh semi ring
simmerings over arbitrary I mean data
log over arbitrary semi ranks so how
interesting
but there is a problem with monos which
is that
n of X is not the mono semi you can
Define monos in N of X but it is not a
monosemite freely generated by X so you
cannot do this trick with uh do the
provenance and then
um and then apply it to various
situations you can still do quite a bit
as you have shown
yes
[Music]
look like
um
uh you just do minus on the coefficients
of you do monus on the coefficients of
every monomial
yeah
even if the monomial is not there if
it's not there then the coefficient is
zero right
okay
and another uh slightly annoying thing
is that semi-ring homomorphisms do not
in general preserve most
so
you can't quite you know
Just Dance Like You Dance before it's
not so easy
um so it's not clear how we can how far
we can take the monosemite it was
applied again in your work with
carbonarakis it was applied to that
query language for the semantic web
called Sparkle yeah so there are some
interesting applications
the second approach that was tried is to
encode negation via aggregation I'm not
going to say much about it but it's not
our idea it's uh Christoph cove's idea
and it appeared in after we defined the
semi uh submitting weakness emitting
framework for aggregation we said oh
let's do also negation that way
the problem is that if you look at
relation algebra identity is involving
negation evolving different relational
difference
some identities are satisfied in one
approach but not in the other and vice
versa we have a whole paper on making
all these comparisons
so for a while I personally had given up
on negation and then I met this man Eric
riddle so
so the third approach that was tried and
that's the most fruitful so far is take
everything to negation normal form
okay
all right
so that actually give us the semantics
for entire first order logic and what
what actually enticed any uh more than
me is that it also gives you a very
interesting semantics for model checking
games and not just for first Audiology
but also for fixed Point logic
and we have some papers along these
lines which I I will probably give a
talk in the program in one of our
informal seminars sometime I have a
whole one hour talk about this including
so now because you can do this you can
talk about negative information you can
talk about why something is not in the
answer of a query not just why it is
Providence tells you why something is in
the answer of a query but you want to
know why isn't something else that you'd
expect it maybe okay so that's a rather
comprehensive way of you can also talk
about why is an Integrity constraint if
the Integrity constraint can be captured
in first order logic you can talk about
why it's failing
although for functional dependencies I
know for Kieran is not very happy with
how that is is explained
Okay so
and then actually we were able to extend
this to fix Point logic with a very
powerful logic it extends first so the
logic with least to explain the greatest
fixed point of
well it has to to be of monotone
functions
um and the right semi ring there we
discovered was this absorptive
polynomials
and we have a paper that you can also
it's in the bibliography you can consult
uh so what's wrong with this
well relational difference is not
compositional that is in order to give
semantics to relational difference you
express it in first of the logic push
the negations all the way to the to the
leaves and yeah yeah
so if you don't give a damn about
relational algebra there's no problem
and you're you are a logician so Eric
now has
several PhD students who have been exp
exploring logic where the notion of
Truth is in a semi-ring instead of the
classical notion of Truth and it's um
it's quite nice
so
there's a lot more provenance than what
I had time to overview to the survey
here
you can do it for uh languages which are
not for flat relations but for nested
relations and Forex query
um and I have some pointers to that
you can do it for
crazed with Aggregates the concept there
for dealing with Aggregates is you need
to consider Aggregates as semi-modules
over the same ring that you are working
with provenance
so that's too much algebra and I decided
not we we jointly decided not to talk
about that
um
it was Daniel deutsche's Group at Tel
Aviv University Uval Moscow which Amid
gilad and others have done a lot of work
quite a few papers about about
provenance including for something
called Data Centric processes which in
which we kind of extend things uh to
relational queries plus and temporal
logic queries
uh uh data log and Dan's gonna talk
about it but Dan's perspective is a
little different our original
perspective was what's the provenance of
data log answers right and you'll be I
think very interested in the the
how they approach
data log
and
there also this is not exactly there's
work that was done before us in uh AI on
constrained satisfaction problems so
there are connections with generalized
constraint satisfaction problems
um work done by Hugo montanari and his
students primarily by Stefano bistarelli
is going to be here in November
yeah so we'll hear more from that
things to do a few suggestions
so mine are not Concrete technical
questions but rather close to Arms
you can certainly look at containment
equivalence for semi-rings that TJ did
not study like absorptive
but I would like to suggest let's start
with with the integers it's a way to
wait a minute that's not a naturally
okay so I'm not talking about
containment in the usual sense
but actually uh comparing
the semantics
over relations annotated with with
integers is very interesting and that's
interesting because of some other work
that I hope to talk about it here
on incremental view maintenance
and so paper that actually will be in
a bldb next week
so we have should have a lecture on
Friday
and we have and then I don't know how
related it is to dbsp probably it's
totally unreal
but I I would like to give a talk about
that as well and I'm really interested
in
queries in which uh the tuples are
annotated with integers
okay so nice thank you okay but maybe
this is the most important to judge them
so from the beginning provenance was
seen as a kind of
causality without without having
followed the work
[Music]
connections there that have not been
completely analyzed uh in particular I'm
fascinated and I'd I'd like us to
revisit responsibility and resilience if
we use more expressive resilience I
learned from Alexandra his recent uh
Jersey recent work yeah
um and Wolfgang uh so I I think that
prominence polynomials or they might
give us a more modulated notion of
causality if we can
uh and
once more into the breach to conquer
negation I don't know
three you can say Three Times Lucky
because with the three three times and
every time it wasn't quite quite right
perfect but we'll see
and finally uh there's all this work on
fixed Point logic what's really
interesting about fixed Point logic is
that not only can you express in fixed
Point logic
data log with negation specifically
stratified data log
and I want to talk about the crazy
things like inflationary data loggers
I'm talking about stratified data it's
quite easy to understand but you can
also Express temporal logics
the new calculus CTL LTL
and people who are if there are formal
methods people are interested in CTL and
so on and they have background and so on
it would be really interesting to
understand how to use absurptive
polynomial provenance for fixed Point
logic applied to something like say cctl
and I think that's it am I over time
under time perfect we have a lot of time
for questions so as I said all these
things are here the
you can find in my
in my talk you can find in my slides
references to uh
to the you can find the bibliography
[Applause]
[Music]
uh can you mentioned that when it comes
to Great containment uh yeah
I sympathize okay
so
thank you
in which is this guy
so one of them is why this this is what
you see
so the Y submitting the elements are
sets of sets
ambition is Union
it's an either importance emitting so
the order is just inclusion
but what's weird about Y is weird is its
multiplication so the multiplication is
you have a set of sets and a set of sets
and what you do is you pairwise Union
set inside the sets
which one was this one the diagram the
last diagram
yeah maybe I should I should go it's
okay let me go to
here
I didn't want to be here at all
that's good
this is the other one which
is
so this is why and this is which
they are quite similar but somehow any
sandwich which
contained so the containment under why
lies containment under natural numbers
and containment under National numbers
implies containment under which
uh I don't know I mean so
look I mean there are many such
interesting situations but so after a
while you learn not to attack but if
you're asking can you use the decision
procedures here to say something about
astronaut I don't believe
foreign
[Music]
yes so we do have
we do have the nested relational
calculus in which you can express
grouping
and look so there is no clean work of
both but if you express grouping and
then you do the aggregation from the
other paper with the modules yeah the
same emotions you can get there so so we
implemented this paper we implemented
the group aggregation in Dubai using the
idea of these papers
there are
so there is a so the nested relational
calculus paper is did not have enough
impact because
we made the mistake to put XML in the
title
and uh as you know XML is not fashion so
so this was at the at the complete tail
end of the fashionable times
but actually uh you can have a you know
what else you can do
there is a
a language that you can Define for an
arbitrary semit in k
in which the data consists of every
nested combination of records and case
sets
so it's it's Nest K nested K relations
yes
and the operation from natural
relational algebra generalizes very
nicely to K sets so you view the groups
asking is nesting as possible yeah so so
you can build the the groups and then of
course in order to to get aggregation
you have to apply the aggregation
I can point you to that
so actually Peter and I uh we are trying
to to note there's something I didn't
say I just didn't say the words were
provenance we're trying to figure out
now some provenance for values inside
the two parts using encoding in that
calculus and if I may make it a
bibliographical comment yeah
I see your references there is a very
interesting paper by cosita reuter and
Solomon from the time the three of them
we are in many Borough this is one right
to considered and they continue their
inspired by
okay and
they found conditions on sending it
some of the containment conditions
of the queries are equivalent to the
conditions and SMA for instance they
have a characterization for which
sendings this I give you an account
wait I'm so ashamed I don't know if
these babies are very nice it's very
hard because I remember people and then
thoughts I can tell you that of course I
I was used by Peter to Godzilla but I
didn't know they did this work you know
guys in the old times when you had a
paper that that worked on somebody's on
somebody's work you would send them a
copy remember those times
this is something you might be
interested in Yes sounds like we have a
party
yeah I'm trying I'm trying to blame
other people that I I don't know
shame on me yeah but I asked one maybe
last question
you mentioned that that Orchestra had 30
percent overhead so what's that for
Phoenix the full the general purpose yes
but they were not represented
essential in practice you don't want to
represent provenance as polynomials
because it's like a normal form okay
it's not an exponential blowout but it's
okay what you want to do in practice is
represent them as arithmetic circuits
that use common sub Expressions as much
as possible moreover what another
interesting thing that happened in
Orchestra is of course we were
interested in real queries real queries
are not good inquiries real queries
actually produce a set of tuples and if
you look at the provenance of the tuples
that are together in an answer they have
a lot of commercial Expressions so we
use those also only once in the problem
yeah it was for n of X yeah and uh
so so the provenance for an answer was a
graph
and actually after that we also wrote a
paper on how to query that graph if you
want to have a query language on
provenance
for some reason
now I may ask the last question so we
work on optimization and I wonder if if
you implement this and run a very
through the optimizer pipeline there'll
be a lot of rewritings right yeah
somebody writings might actually turn a
positive query into the negative one
like you might use uh I don't know set
difference
application even though the input query
yeah is positive so now things might
start to break I I agree we only gotta
see we only guarantee soundness with
respect to those
Transformations which are actually uh in
the the kind of basic Transformations
you do for uh Bank semantics
uh for set semantics if you are careful
not to not to use
you know
you you can you can use the Boolean
polynomials but uh but if you actually
do rewritings introducing difference
or better
um
because it's interesting because you you
also have query minimization and all
kinds of interesting
the chase is very much dependent on on
set semantics so
yes right thank you vowel I think we are
at time so
um thanks well again and we will resume
at two with switch gears to Virginia uh
track on fine grain complexity